well today marks the start of black
history month all month long we will
share
stories about important contributions of
local black leaders and families
we'll start at the neon museum where
rocky theos joins us live with more
on its exhibits on the sites with those
deep roots in both las vegas and black
history hi rocky
hey kirsten that was such a fabulous
introduction because what i love
most about the neon museum is that it
illuminates black history all year round
it's not just in february right don
absolutely so i get a private tour of
the neon museum with the vice president
of the neon museum so
i'm lucky today yeah well come along so
let's start with the moulin rouge
because this is
by far one of my favorite signs one of
the newer newly restored signs here at
the museum right
it's had it's not fully restored but
we've redid the neon on it
and you can see that some of it looks
more pink and some of it looks more red
the red stuff is from 1955. it still
worked they just put the gas in it and
we were off and running
i love it and as as the sun goes down
the neon lights get brighter and it's
becoming
more and more beautiful as the time goes
so let's take a walk down
history lane and talk about the black
history behind the mount rouge
well this was the first racially
integrated casino hotel in las vegas
at the time when black entertainers came
here they could perform on the strip but
they couldn't stay on this trip
so they would come and they would stay
here and became very popular
with the rat pack and they would come
and do another show at 2 30 in the
morning and the place would be packed
and it was
imagine that it was amazing don't you
wish you could go back in time and i
know right
see the dancers and everything beautiful
and i understand there was a
certain really important meeting that
happened there as well right yes
that meeting led to um segregation going
away in las vegas
they had a meeting with the west side
leaders with the governor
other prominent people and they came to
an agreement called the moulin rouge
agreement
and that eventually led to segregation
finally going away in las vegas wow so
you can come down here to the neon
museum and get a history lesson with a
guided tour of course or you can come
and take a walk on your own and last but
not least here
lance can you get the fitzgerald really
quick before we have to go back the
fifth gerald sign
what's the tidbit there the fitzgerald
sign was owned by don barton at one time
and he was one of the
first african americans to have a uh to
own a hotel it's now where the d
is located wow okay that is two just two
of the signs coming up later in the show
we're gonna show you
a few more that has to do with the neon
museum's logo absolutely must be very
special we'll send it back to you
all right thanks very much rocky love
the neon museum there's a fun scavenger
hunt too you can do once you download
the app while you're there